eduardo do me a favor give me the exact
day
that nixon resigned the presidency
this is important good story he's
sending a runner off now yes written on
a piece of paper
someone in a beekeeper's outfit made of
beef jerky august 8 1974 is when he gave
his resignation speech okay uh is that
the day he gets on the helicopter
you should know that august 8th okay
it's important that i get this right
nixon resigned from office on august 9
1970 okay according to wikipedia okay
okay august 8th 1974. this is a true
story my parents there's a woman who
came and helped out my parents for a
little bit there were six of us my
parents are working
and then she
departed the family she was like moving
on to something else and she had come
from i think nova scotia and so she
gifted us a bunch of little baby chicks
little uh little you know
little ducklings
and she gave us these and we kept them
in a little we didn't know what we were
doing but we just kept them in the
backyard and we put a piece of little
fence around them
and
we had them for like two or three days
the backdrop for three days i'm just
saying two or three days prior to this
story we had them hold on hold on oh
yeah i thought you meant but no no no so
we had that we had well maybe you're
really fun people to tell a story
sorry so both of you have a nice slice
of [ __ ] yourself pie you're the worst
it's just the worst
i'm sorry i'm sorry no no it's good it's
terrific anyway is there pie yeah
so
anyway
that's the story is when our little
backyard we have this we've made a
little circle of mesh and these little
baby chicks are in there going
and we're we're literally watching nixon
resign on television in brookline
massachusetts you're like 11 right uh
yeah we're watching nixon resign he's
like
i'm gonna resign
that's pretty much how it went kids look
it up
oh they got me they got me good i'm out
of here yeah i gotta go we're gonna
resign tomorrow uh that's what's gonna
happen she and so
nixon's resigning and all of a sudden we
hear all this insane shrieking oh no in
the backyard and we grab flashlights and
we run out there and
raccoons oh no had totally held her
skeltered oh our chicks and what i saw
were little webbed feet
they chomped the birds and then like it
was an appetizer yes i think they held
the birds by the little webbed feet and
chomped them and then put them back like
that's the toothpick that you
put in the napkin for the waiter that's
what the [ __ ] raccoons did they
chomped it and then they put the little
feet down oh no and one of the i guess
ducks was nonchalant because its little
legs were crossed kind of no yeah it was
very nonchalant duck
and so i think he was just leaning
against the the the mesh
and he got chomped but his legs were
stuck in this very cool i don't you know
i don't give two [ __ ] sort of pose but
i guess now he does
and the raccoons took off that is my
memory of whenever i see any footage or
any picture of nixon resigning
all i can think about are those little
duck feet in our backyard their feet
left behind
tearing up are you laughing those
butchers those butchers that's just
horrible those butchers that's the worst
well that's the worst story i've ever
heard well it's a campfire
yeah i don't think those those little
things weren't going to make it anyway
come on we didn't take care of stuff
one of my brothers didn't make it
ben
no one looked after ben brian
yeah ben was the one after justin and no
one gave a [ __ ]